over the past few bigquery spotlight
episodes
we've walked you through the
fundamentals of bigquery
to help you get started architecting and
administering your warehouse
today we're going beyond that initial
setup and talking about how you can
ensure
that your bigquery environment stays
cost effective
performant and secure through ongoing
[Music]
monitoring
monitoring your data warehouse on a
continuous basis
is important for every organization
let's walk through
a few key use cases so that you can
understand the different data sources
available to monitor and the types of
questions you might be asking for each
one
first up cost optimization
one of the ways you can monitor bigquery
spend and google cloud spend in general
is to leverage the billing reports you
can analyze billing data directly
in the google cloud console or export it
back into bigquery to join it against
other data sets and create your own
custom reports
let's jump into the cloud console to
take a look
in the reports tab of the billing page
we can see a chart with our cost for a
particular billing account
broken down by project service sku
or even label keys focusing on bigquery
services
there are a few different actions you
might want to take
using this data first off you can see
how much money is being spent on
bigquery across different teams or
projects
and use this to set up budgets and
notifications
so that you or others on your team know
if spend is getting out of hand
or you can even set up custom quotas for
bigquery
so that specific users or projects are
limited in the amount of data they can
process
next you might want to dig into the
storage skus to look at a breakdown
of active versus long-term storage
in case you don't already know bigquery
charges half the price for data that has
not been modified in 90 days
this includes entire tables or specific
partitions within a table
so this information may be able to help
you modify the way you update data
or narrow down tables that could be
partitioned to take advantage of
long-term storage
another skew you may see in the billing
data is for streaming inserts
while bigquery charges for streaming
inserts batch loading is free
so if data being streamed into bigquery
doesn't need to be consumed right away
you might consider editing your loading
process
finally the billing reports can be super
helpful for pinpointing projects that
have spikes in analysis
cost here analysis means on-demand
querying
where you're charged for the amount of
bytes scanned
there might be an opportunity to apply a
slot reservation
to these projects to save costs and
ensure predictable pricing
if you're not familiar with bigquery
reservations or bigquery pricing model
i highly recommend that you go and visit
our jobs and reservations video
linked below now if you do decide to go
with flat rate pricing
you'll need to figure out what
reservation size makes the most sense
for your needs
this brings us to our second use case
workload management and performance
monitoring
you can see how many slots were consumed
across different workloads
in your organization using the cloud
monitoring interface
or the information schema tables
natively available in bigquery
for example if your historical slot
consumption looks like this
you may want to find the baseline and
purchase a monthly or annual slot
commitment for that amount
in this case around 500 slots for
queries that are causing those peaks
you could choose to purchase a flex lock
commitment
run the query and then cancel the
commitment
and as a reminder the number of
available slots
is kind of like a measure of throughput
this means that if less slots are
available
the query will likely just run slower
you can always test out query
performance with different number of
slots
to find the size that works best for
your needs
besides just determining the size of
your reservation
you may also want to use cloud
monitoring or the information schema
to monitor job performance and actually
if you're using slot reservations
already you can also use the new
bigquery admin
resource charts let's take a look
this data can help you pinpoint queries
that should be optimized
like this scheduled query that seems to
be consuming a lot of resources
with the job id you can even get the
execution details
and use some of the optimization
techniques we covered in our previous
video
to figure out if you can rewrite the sql
to be more efficient
you might also want to dig into job
concurrency to rearrange scheduling for
optimal spot utilization
or failed jobs to help troubleshoot any
ongoing issues
okay great so we've reviewed some ways
to save money
and optimize performance now let's talk
about how you can audit
data sharing and access using cloud
logging
which allows you to analyze system and
application log data
and just like our other data sources
logs can be analyzed in the console
or exported into bigquery in one of our
previous videos
we talked about data governance you
might remember that we use data catalog
to develop policy tags for controlling
access
in cloud logging we can do things like
find the email address for the principal
that grants or removes access on a
policy tag
or the email address for whom the access
was granted or removed
you can also directly see what user
identities have queried which data
sources
to ensure that all access policies are
correct
and no one has access to data that they
shouldn't
as you can see monitoring is essential
to making informed decisions on
optimizing your bigquery data warehouse
as a quick review you can use the
billing data to create budgets custom
quotas
and dig into areas where you can reduce
costs
to size reservations improve performance
and troubleshoot errors
you can use cloud monitoring or the
information schema
or if you're a reservation customer the
new bigquery admin resource charts
finally you can use cloud logging to
review granular log data
which also might be useful for
troubleshooting and to monitor data
access policies
the great part of monitoring in bigquery
is that you have the flexibility to
export
any of these data sources back into your
data warehouse
for custom reporting in fact
we've even built a series of data studio
and looker templates
to accelerate any additional analysis
you want to do
on top of billing information schema or
log data
make sure to check out the links below
for details and follow me on social to
get more bigquery tips and tricks
oh and remember stay curious